hello class welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel today I'm going
to be doing a lesson as usual but before
I start don't forget to subscribe to the
channel and ring that notification Bell
that way you're going to be notified of
my daily videos today I have my lovely
student Jess what's up this is Brad till
101. okay
So today we're going to talk about
virginity yay so what do you know about
virginity a lot now do what do men value
for virginity why do they value it
because she's not ran through
good good job Josh good job so in most
cases virginity is the most valuable
thing you can give to a guy it is so
powerful like that that is the most
beautiful gift you can give to someone
however there are times when you're a
virginity doesn't count
now you're asking
why is that okay now I'll give you an
example number one
your will
now well whales are a beautiful Majestic
creature
men aren't lining up to date fat chicks
a dude will take an only Fan's model
with a hundred bodies
before he takes a fat chick I'm sorry I
don't make the rules
don't hate the player hate the game it
just is what it is you have to be a
certain level of good looking to get in
the club
number two number two I think you hate
for myself
you
your
ugly
your virginity doesn't count if you're
ugly because again
blessing if your girl's face looks like
it was smashed in with a baseball bat
so but she's a virgin or or
you get a girl that's that's pretty hot
but you know like 10 20 bodies
[Laughter]
virginity it's it's valuable but it's
not valuable if you're a whale you're
ugly nobody's lining up to date ugly fat
chicks I don't make the rules
yeah and so a lot of girls will be like
I'm a virgin I'm a virgin and it's like
great ma'am but nobody's trying to no
one's trying to mess with you no one's
trying to mess with you so it's like
okay yeah you turn down losers that were
trying to screw you but like
yeah so
anyways Point number three your
virginity doesn't count
if
you're well um
oh yeah I forgot
you're old
okay now men value youth right youth
goes with Purity but if you're over a
certain age like let's take Lolo Jones
nobody's lining up for a 40 year 41 year
old virgin like blessing would you
rather have a 21 year old with 10 bodies
or a 41 year old with zero
yeah like you can
if you're if you're over the age of
I
should we give them 28
I say 30. third well they'll do 30 okay
men are starting to question what's
wrong with you why are you a virgin at
30. it's pretty natural for people to
want to have sex but you've made it to
almost halfway through your life so
you're either
lying
like if a girl tells you she's 30 and a
virgin do you believe her
going back to point number two but yeah
which goes back to point number one and
two
you're lying or or
you're too picky
because let me think you've been in the
game since you were 16 18 and you're
telling me not one guy could live up to
your standards
too picky
something
is wrong
with
you
mentally
now a lot of virgins get this I'm better
than everyone attitude
where they just think they're God's gift
to the Earth because they have that no
one else has touched like I'm sorry at
the end of the day it's still just
vagina you ain't like like I still just
look for the kids yeah and if a dude is
looking at you and saying this is a new
BMW okay like let's say you're the new
BMW or I could get a slightly used BMW
for a lot lower price for like 70
percent off
with you know some mileage but low
mileage
like if you if you just
are a lot of work
blessing who you picking
uh
low right because it's like the outside
is pretty but the inside is just yucky
no one wants to have to change the
engine uh exhaust tank tires yeah on a
brand new car yeah and he's like this
new which which brings me to point
number four
it doesn't count if you're selfish
and argumentative
blessing he's the only guy here so we
gotta use him blessing do you want to
come home
and argue
do you want to come home and have a girl
that didn't cook you dinner because
she's only thinking about herself
and do you care if she's a virgin if
she's selfish and argumentative
so you're virgin it just doesn't count
like it's like all the value that you
had to a guy
is gone he'll go he'll take he'll take
the only Fan's model
that's been with everybody before he
takes your selfish argumentative ass and
what you'll do is you'll go to the
market and say I'm a virgin and I think
I deserve new prices and on the outside
guys we're like yeah here let me let me
check my wallet but then when they did
the test drive
maybe not a test drive but the when I
look at I don't know that's not the
right word
analogies when they look at the car when
they really inspect it they say
um
when they look at the specs sheet show
me the Carfax
they see wow this this girl is selfish
argumentative she thinks she's better
than everyone else and she just is a
headache
and so they don't even give a [ __ ] that
you're a virgin because if you're not
nice
he doesn't care
and that is why a lot of virgins
not a lot I won't say a lot because most
girls will just lose it but
um
some virgins I'll say
die
alone
because
yeah so stop bragging about your
virginity if you're well stop bragging
about your virginity if you're ugly stop
bragging about your virginity if you're
old it's not bragging about your
virginity if you're selfish and
argumentative because no one is trying
to screw you anyway
class dismissed